[Laughter]
guys these are some high-velocity
projectile long before I came here I
heard about the Brahmastra or as it's
colloquially called the Philosopher's
Stone as he knows this is vegetable
stand down Gavin oh you already worked
great we need you on my way I got it I
figured it out would listen Harry
maybe if instead of nope will be really
extra covers his ears before the thing
happens what is it you don't know any of
your lives you know I don't like you
Julien Julien that's me yeah it's your
choice
frequent unexplained absences your love
for matters that cheeky little smile so
you're just traveling time and kiss
other versions me with you everything
I'm gonna do this may do it right what
does that mean it means if I'm gonna put
while at risk I'm gonna use everything
in my power to protect them look at my
suit everyone sounds like the teacher
from peanuts when you're wearing this
thing
[Music]
hey everybody get some flash bloopers
they just dropped the season 3 DVD so
that's why this is posting now I cut a
little bit of it out just because in
context I wanted to talk about what's
happening with the big crossover
episodes this season
danielle panabaker was at DragonCon this
past weekend she answered like a couple
really big questions so we'll say
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video if there is something else you
guys want me to do for the giveaway this
season because it'll be happening every
week just let me know like if you want
it to be something different from the
flash ring but there's like an unlimited
amount of those so I can keep doing that
for as long as you guys want but just a
reminder that winners are usually
announced at the end of videos like I'll
say your name in the video if you won
the giveaway but as you can see from
that like there's a whole lot of Caitlyn
in those bloopers I totally love it when
she drops f-bombs because she's so nice
she actually seems like she's more
suited for Disney Channel level stuff so
it's just so much more funny when she
swears like a sailor it's so great if
she ever gets to go on Titan's on the DC
streaming service and they let her swear
even more it's gonna be hilarious but
she confirmed at the beginning of the
season she's not automatically going to
be on Team flash she said for like the
top of the season so that could be a
couple episodes but we see her in the
trailer which is footage from the first
episode inside STAR Labs as Caitlin snow
with Captain colds gun so she said
they're sort of picking the pieces up
and Wally's taking point irises trying
to bring everyone together they're
trying to cobble together a team flash
while Barry is still away once he comes
back and they get their [ __ ] together
that's presumably when she'll come back
the team flash she only said she
wouldn't be an official team flash
member for the top of the season
remember she confirmed that there would
be a time jump which I think we all knew
like it'd be about the standard six
months that goes between the finale in
the first episode so not a big surprise
there but she did confirm that there
were no plans for another musical
crossover episode so that sort of the
footage that I cut out of this there was
some footage in the blooper reel of them
behind the scenes on that musical
crossover that I felt like didn't quite
fit with the other blooper stuff so I
just chopped it out
so whether you're really excited that
they're not gonna try and do a musical
crossover again or if you really liked
it and you're sad that they're not gonna
do it that doesn't mean that they'll
never do something like that again but
typically they try not to recycle ideas
too much which is why I like they're not
doing another speedster villain so I
actually think it's good that they're
not trying to do the exact same thing
again because technically it was a
really good achievement but I think the
problem is is that like most of their
audience is looking for a comic-book
show and that was like the least comic
book episode ever so it was like really
awesome that they were able to pull it
off but I don't think it wound up being
quite as popular with the audience as
they hoped it could have been when they
could have just done a straight-up
superhero crossover and then just done
like some drunken karaoke at a dive bar
afterwards but if you guys didn't know
there's actually New York Comic Con
that's gonna be happening the week
before the flash and arrow premiere all
the DC TV shows so there isn't going to
be any kind of DC TV panel there is like
a Gotham panel but technically that's
not DC TV because it's not connected to
the other shows DC TV is really referred
to as the CW TV shows but because that's
right around when they'll be shooting
the big four-way crossover they'll be
busy doing that and because it's so
close to the premiere there's no point
in them doing a big comic-con panel so
what'll probably happen is they'll just
release some extra trailers that weekend
because if you remember the last couple
of trailers they released before season
3 started we're sort of like hey you
know this is my character this is how
things are gonna be different it was
basically stuff like this
Oh is there a better way to get to work
than by helicopter let me answer that
capital in a little the repercussions of
berry changing the timeline span all
across the spectrum for all of our
character so they'll probably be a lot
of that the week before the flash comes
back but leading up to that they release
little promo so there'll be more footage
for the first couple of episodes I'm
expecting them to keep things relatively
close to the best until we see berry
full-blown and one of the promos then
they'll stop doing the Justice League
Superman thing where it's like we know
he's coming back but you want to keep
him out of the promos because there's a
certain element of surprise and you'd
actually probably be blown away by the
number of people that you know have no
idea what's going on with flash rebirth
in the comics they don't know that
Barry's coming back I got so many
questions after the finale about whether
or not Barry was really coming back but
obviously once episodes come back
Tuesday will be a big flash day I know I
still do a lot of Game of Thrones on
Tuesdays right now so we'll just remind
everyone with the video schedule is
gonna be in a couple weeks when
everything comes back because arrows
move to a different night so there'll be
like a few minor changes but if you were
subscribed to me last year around this
time then you have a pretty good idea of
the videos that I'll be doing
congratulations to the latest flash ring
giveaway winner germinator 83 please
private message me so I can get your
contact details just a reminder about
the flash ring - I'll remind everyone
win episodes start because there's
always a lot of new people that
subscribe around that time is that when
I ask people to leave comments as a way
to enter the giveaway you're not really
supposed to comment just give me the
flash ring so I'll try to remind people
about that the giveaways are meant to be
random and if you ask for the giveaway
and then I give it to you then it's not
random so I'll try to explain that to
people I think it's mostly younger
people that comment that they don't
quite understand so I'll try to remind
people about that whenever we get
started this season but I'll be posting
a non-spoilery Inhumans review next it
was not what I expected so while you
wait for that you can click here for
more brand new flash and you can click
here for more brand new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight